et live is backstage at the Latin AMAs
with one of the performers of the night
Amelia madness
felicidades amazing performance thank
you so much Mussina okay okay Napoleon
get shot bastard moment but thank you
for having me I'm so excited yes No
thank you for being here and Quinton
awesome Paquito que esta pasando por
comment and ella scenario blanco na
hoona
but i try it try to speak because i need
learn ha ha ha ha
right your lorry right here on UT live
your you're rising like everything in
your career is just getting started so I
mean it's just putting the work in we
were just talking about she's gonna be
performing at the look Luther in
Argentina cherry is a creepy car make a
case on looking for time you know
Argentina is having such a moment right
now especially in Latin music there's
you there's Lally how's it feel to be
representing your home country Clementi
in Tokyo so he told us in processor is
Italian as a transition is incredible a
mi siento parte movimiento M okay sir
messy Conestoga's el mundo se quedó me
company at a slightly teeny castle oh my
god this goes on and on yeah me I love
it no she's definitely turning the love
with all the women and you're all about
girl power on Instagram you're all about
it you show a lot of love specifically
to Anita Oh Annie I love I love her it
says Wow look gonna see much okay oh my
gosh but it's ready to open in easy
opening and I'm gonna say this is a show
he is not more she's amazing really any
collaboration try to work with you know
maybe God can hear you you know
say it out loud okay speak this into
existence help me with with money that
she's watching she's what I think she's
thinking you know she's gonna call you
right after this she has an idea fresh
I'm gonna call you up after the
craziness ends okay after the Latin may
amaze now I gotta say something we were
on the red carpet and we were speaking
to CNC oh and then he asked them if they
were still single because the last time
they spoke they were all single and the
first one to answer with a holy Lord
just found out to be very interesting
let's have a lot of chemistry in that
music video I'm sure about that that
answer you know okay that's a pretty
mama pero no I'm more that movie no no
I'm willing to question Melinda's a that
interest in evening can tell I guess and
100-lap remember and no supposed to put
a mio second of alessio nakedness it a
yeah but I don't know how I'd say about
that you know are you single yeah I am
seeing yes I need a boyfriend please my
Instagram at any requirement what any
requirement you looking for in a man oh
my god I don't know Tomica gimme
cast-in-place genomic era pour pour pour
pour Emilia Cantante Singapore poor
Emilia Paulo case dentro de leyva sea
canola care for Amelia can Tonto because
Emilia consent is gonna take off what is
coming in 2020
music scores Tonto a Aruba no como como
Valera's I play the guitar
this is easy okay I like I like it so
much the Pallavas and I love seeing
aesthetically consciouness
y momentum mucho musica para yeah I love
that and a collaboration with Anita
we're gonna say it again I love you and
I have a son for you what is the song is
that a ballad or is a item death
felicidades enjoy the evening and thank
you so much for being with Attila thank
you so much
are you guys eat see live is backstage
at the Latin AMAs more interviews with
the performers and the winners coming up
[Music]
[Applause]